when we learned about social security we
saw that the people who are currently
working are paying their FICA taxes
those essentially those revenues are
being used directly to provide the
Social Security benefits for existing
retirees and other beneficiaries and any
surplus goes to the Social Security
trust and when you had this baby boomer
generation on the left-hand side of this
of this system right here so the baby
boomer generation is this huge
population boom that happened after
World War two after after you know the
country was happy and all the soldiers
had come back they produced a lot of
babies and it was so you had this
population boom and when this population
boom was on the left-hand side of the
system they were able to generate a lot
of revenue to supply for the benefits
for essentially their parents generation
and so that did help build the surplus
the problem is is that they didn't
produce that the population did not grow
as much in the next generation and you
could do that as a problem or a good
thing but it's a problem in the context
of Social Security because starting
recently and over the next few decades
this baby baby boom generation is going
to move on to the right-hand side of
this equation and we saw that it will
they will start they will start to
drawdown even this surplus fairly soon
and that because of this this
demographic change the Social Security
surplus will be completely depleted
between 2030 and 2040 Medicare is very
similar you have some portion of the
FICA tax is for Medicare and that that
revenue is used to paid for the health
benefits of the retirees and the surplus
goes into a Medicare trust and that
Medicare trust of the formal name is the
hospital insurance trust fund the
problem with Medicare is that the
situation is even worse the Medicare
trust the Medicare or I guess we could
say the Medicare system is already
running at a deficit meaning that
they're spending more money on the right
they're spending more money on the right
than they're getting in on the left so
they're already starting to drawdown
already starting to draw down their
trust so Social Security at least the
trust is continuing to grow until 2023
or that's our best estimate right now
then it'll start drawing down and it'll
get depleted in 20 between 2030 to 24
in Medicare situations a lot worse so in
Medicare we are already starting to draw
down the trust we are already spending
more in beneficiaries than we're taking
down it then we were taking in FICA
revenues and the entire trust based on
our current assumptions will probably be
depleted in the next ten years depleted
depleted in next ten years and what
makes Medicare especially troubling
despite the fact that it's in a kind of
a worse financial position is that these
costs are growing even faster and I want
to be clear a lot of people think that
though so for Social Security the main
problem with this system over here is
the demographic changes you have this
huge population that's retiring the baby
boomers which makes this not sustainable
but with Medicare that's also going on
but what makes Medicare even a bigger
problem than Social Security is above
and beyond those demographic changes
above and beyond these this baby boomer
generation retiring instead of paying
into Medicare taking benefits from
Medicare the big problem is that you
actually have medical healthcare costs
going up well above the cost of
inflation for Social Security these
people's benefits could just go up with
inflation for Medicare the benefits go
up with the cost of medical care and
that's going well above the cost of
inflation and so you have this situation
where based on current benefits and our
best assumptions about the economy and
the FICA taxes coming in you kind of
have a reality where if you had to give
the current benefits and if you expect
medical costs healthcare costs to
continue to increase at the rate they're
doing and there's no sign frankly that
it is stopping then you have this
reality that Medicare left unchecked
could add right now it's roughly about
23 percent of our budget 23 24 percent
of our budget or about 4 percent of our
GDP so here we are in 2011 it's about 4%
of our GDP we're spending on Medicare
and Medicaid and Medicaid is essentially
health benefits for mainly the poor it's
run by the states but it gets federal
funding so right now that's 4 percent of
GDP but because of the cost growth in in
health care costs and if we leave it
completely unchecked over the next 50 60
years
it could grow to 15 16 17 % of GDP and
just to be clear that's the that's the
percentage of GDP that aren't that's
roughly our entire federal budget so
this has the potential if we don't grow
our budget any to actually crowd out a
lot of other things and just to
understand this graph a little bit they
show they [ __ ] they show the part of the
part in the cost of Medicare the part of
the growth do two different things this
is the effect of aging population this
is the effect of excess cost growth and
then this is the interaction of the two
and to understand why that makes sense
you just have to think about the total
costs being the product of the number
maybe you could say the net number of
recipients because some people are
paying in as well but this will
hopefully help you understand what I'm
talking about number of recipients
number of recipients times times the
cost per recipient so let's say that
this is the cost per recipient cost per
recipient cost per recipient so if you
take the number of recipients times the
cost per recipient you're gonna get the
total costs let's say that's the total
cost today so that's that would be the
area of that square we're just
multiplying the base times the height so
current costs current annual cost
current costs now because of demographic
changes you're going to have some
increase in the net number of recipients
so you're going to have some increase
there but because of medical cost growth
you're going to have a big increase in
the cost per recipient so this thing is
going to increase much more and so if
you go to some future point and you can
pick your future point but I'm really
just trying to make you understand why
we have these three categories the total
cost is going to be that total cost per
recipient that has grown dramatically
times the total number of recipients and
so now you're talking about this area
this area is going to be the total cost
and if you think about how much of this
total cost is due purely to the
increased cost growth well it would be
this part right over here this part
would be the amount the cost the
increase in the area true purely due to
the increased cost growth so that would
be this part of the graph right over
here what part of this increased area is
due purely to the ink
number of recipients well that would be
this part of the graph right over here
purely due to the increased number
recipients and that is right over here
effect of aging population and then you
have some part of this area that's
created by both the increase in the
number recipients and the increase in
cost and that's going to be that's going
to be this area right over here which is
this part of the graph so when people
talk about the unsustainable well one we
have an unsustainable debt to begin with
the second thing is is that the
liabilities the obligations that we have
aren't even on these aren't even counted
in the government deficit and these are
the things that are really really scary
because something has to give so in all
of this the the single factor that's
this kind of driving most of the
scariness is Medicare in particular and
not just Medicare but it's it's not just
the demographic changes but specific to
Medicare is to increase costs of health
care so if somehow that nut can be
cracked if health care can all of a
sudden grow maybe just with inflation or
maybe even slightly faster than
inflation but not at the rate it's
growing right now then you could to a
large degree mitigate kind of the
scariness of what's going on with our
with our obligations